- Nobody loves me.
- [Mark] Nobody loves you?
- Nobody cares about me.
That's why I care so little about myself.
- [Mark] And this is why
you do drugs, do you think?
- Mm-hmm.
At least I can feel high a little bit,
a little bit less melancholy.
- [Mark] Takes away the pain?
- Takes away the pain,
so I'm so emotionally distraught.
(indistinct) myself.
I do drugs, so I do drugs.
- [Mark] So your name is Tracy?
- Trixie T. Pardon.
- [Mark] Trixie T.
Pardon, and you're from?
- Jackson, Mississippi.
I'm from Biloxi.
- [Mark] Biloxi.
(Trixie coughing)
- How old do I look?
- [Mark] How old do you look?
I'm guessing...
- Guess a little young.
- [Mark] Guess a little younger?
- 'Cause I have a hard life.
- [Mark] Um...
- A little young.
- [Mark] 40, 45?
- 40.
- [Mark] 40, you're 40?
Well, you're still beautiful.
You have a beautiful face.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] So you're all
dressed up this morning.
- Mm hm.
- [Mark] Are you coming from something?
Were you out partying last night?
Or you're going somewhere?
- No, no party.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- I'm not a party person.
- [Mark] You're not?
- I went to an AA meeting last night.
- [Mark] You went where?
- AA meeting.
- [Mark] AA meeting?
- I'm an alcoholic of sorts.
- [Mark] Yeah.
How long have you been
going to AA meetings?
- All my life.
- [Mark] All your life.
- 'Cause my parents were alcoholics.
- [Mark] And you're living on the street?
- Mm hm, 17 years.
- [Mark] Do you blame alcohol for that?
- [Trixie] No, I blame that
from a man who tricked me at love.
My third husband tricked me at love.
- He tricked-
- I really loved him.
But he tricked me.
(indistinct) 17 years.
- [Mark] And you haven't gotten over that?
- [Trixie] No.
We had one daughter between us.
- [Mark] You have a daughter?
And where is your daughter?
- [Trixie] She's now in a foster home,
I mean, an adopted home.
She was adopted by her foster family.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- [Trixie] He kept turning
up dirty drug tests.
Dirty tests.
Tested dirty too many times.
Took it away from him.
One of the craziest things,
one of the best things.
Best, right?
Does it have to be crazy?
- [Mark] No, just tell me
something interesting about living
on the street.
- I was sitting on a sidewalk
and this fella, you know, he smoked rock,
this fella came up and dropped
20 dollars of cocaine in my lap.
I said, "What's that for?"
And he said, "Nothing, just
because you're my friend."
Very-
- [Mark] That's a friend.
So you're doing, uh...
- [Trixie] I do drugs, only one.
Cocaine.
- [Mark] Cocaine?
- [Trixie] See, I'm a French peasant.
- [Mark] You're a French peasant?
- Mm hm.
I have an English name, though.
- [Mark] And you have one child?
- Mm hm.
- [Mark] And where do you sleep?
Do you have an apartment, hotel?
- Street.
- [Mark] You're living on the street?
- I sleep on the street
if I have blankets.
I have blankets all
(indistinct) pinpoints.
So that when I'm tired, I just
pick up a blanket out there.
- [Mark] And it gets
cold in the winter, no?
- Yeah, it's real cold.
I'm hypothermic.
I have double pneumonia.
- [Mark] And people leave you alone?
You don't get accosted
- No.
- [Mark] being a single
woman on the street?
- No.
I'm getting ready to carry a gun.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- I'm getting ready to pack heat.
- [Mark] Oh.
And you can get a gun here on the street?
- Mm hm.
- [Mark] Yeah, that would
keep the trouble away.
- Mm hm.
- [Mark] And where do you eat?
- I don't.
- [Mark] You don't eat?
- I only eat semen.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- [Mark] You only eat semen?
And you charge for that
or you do that for free?
- Charge ya.
- [Mark] What do you, what
do you charge for that?
- 5 and up.
- [Mark] 5 and up.
And how many times a day do you?
- Only at night.
- [Mark] Only at night?
- During the day I beg.
- [Mark] You beg during the day and you,
- Suck cock all night.
- [Mark] you suck cock all night.
- (laughing) This is
some kind of interview.
- [Mark] Trixie, thank you
very much for talking to me.
- [Trixie] You're welcome.
- [Mark] And letting me photograph you.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] You're beautiful.
- You are too, Mark.
- [Mark] I hope you stay safe out there.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] All right.